this is Startalk we're back on Startalk
and this is the how tweeted is section
we just grabbed one of my tweets from
archives and I'd give you some behind
the scenes I got Bill Nye to help me do
that yes it's good to be hain you tweet
at bill nye yes excellent excellent
so here's a tweet I just I was this
actually happened okay and I was like
angry and I had to share my anger I had
to wait in line to renew a passport
allowing me to visit members of my own
species across artificially conceived
borders gotta take exception you know a
lot of those borders are artificial why
you can't fit in the whole map and a
tweet let me ask you our CEO of the
Planetary Society which not even
thinking about countries no you weren't
thinking about planet planets so you
know let's take that as an example you
should embrace this
you know I'm embracing over I'm here to
challenge you a little why a lot of the
borders a lot of the borders people made
up I have to do with rivers and oceans
okay and then then traditions that
happen when you got rivers oceans and
mountains stuff happens like I can sure
we will when we meet the Martians it'll
all be good and we'll have border
crossings and stuff but they're gonna
want to know where you came from and
what let's say you think the marshes
wanted in the fruit the marshes want to
know where you came from and what
parasites you might be bringing to their
lovely fantastically sterile surface I
tweeted recently by Marxist I said I
can't wait for a Martian to come to land
on Earth and and it says to us take me
to your regular people your common
people that's what I won't forget the
leaders the reason leaders become
leaders is cuz tribes embrace leaders
it's not what it looks like lately in
America Wow we came that close ladies
and gentlemen to getting a political
comment from dr. Tyson I'm that close
this is Startalk